- Can you tell everybody
(audience claps)
about your new show though?
"The Big Shot with Bethany"?
- So "The Big Shot with
Bethany" is a modern version
of "The Apprentice" where
it's about real business,
real brands.
It's about me as a person,
meaning you're seeing me warts and all
and how I'm holding this business together
often with Scotch tape.
It comes from a genuine need
where I need my second in command.
And it's a very different show.
It's very unexpected.
It's showing the truth of my business,
that it's hard, that I hold it together,
that I work like an animal,
and that I need somebody to be my second
to take off some of the pressure.
And it's all totally real.
And it's based on my businesses
versus just manufactured
projects and tasks, integrations.
It's not, it's actually
things that are happening
in the world within my business.
- You are so impressive.
Thank you so much.
It's so nice to have you on the show
but also just to meet you.
- Oh, so nice to meet you too.
Thank you so much.
So funny, at the
beginning of the pandemic,
my daughter and I was singing "Stronger".
Like that was sort of an anthem,
we were playing it
- Yes!
- and just singing it,
(audience claps)
so right before you came on,
- Yes.
- I said to (indistinct) want
you to meet Kelly Clarkson,
and I said, "She's the one who,
you know, sings 'Stronger'."
She's like, "Oh", cause you know,
she's always on Tik Tok,
- Oh.
- so now's she impressed.